bonjour bienvenue chez mon baluchon je
m'appelle sophie keller je suive co
fondatrice de l'entreprise avec mon
associé coralie mon baluchon c'est quoi
c'est un site d'e commerce de proximité
de vente de produits vrac alimentaire et
non alimentaire français bio locaux et
zéro déchet
[Musique]
mon baluchon a été créée donc en mars
2022 on a débuté notre activité le 29
avril dernier voilà le site a ouvert à
ce moment là les gens commentent sur
notre site en ligne voilà les les
produits et leurs contenants puisqu'on a
plusieurs types de contenants des bocaux
des recherches kraft biodégradable mais
aussi des bouteilles consignées voilà il
ya ensuite ils choisissent leurs modes
de livraison donc livraison à domicile
sur le lieu de travail ou en retrait
click and collect et bien du coup ce
matin on va livrer donc sur un lieu de
travail à domicile et on va aussi
recevoir potentiellement une cliente en
retrait en click and collect
[Musique]
quand le client commande sur internet la
commande tombe sur notre back office on
la voit apparaître on regarde le jour de
la livraison ou du click and collect et
on prépare sa commande au plus tôt la
brille
[Musique]
j'ai imprimé les étiquettes de la
commande la commande qui est tombée sur
sur internet donc on a décidé de le
choix de faire des étiquettes et
d'indiquer un conseil d'utilisation très
pratique pour le consommateur
par exemple le temps de cuisson là nous
avons 500 g de pois chiches donc nous
allons aller vers les pois chiches
[Musique]
tous nos aliments sont dans des boîtes
hermétiques
pour un côté de conservation des
aliments cette cliente a fait le choix
du papier kraft pour le pois chiche donc
elle doit certainement déjà avoir ses
propres mots qu elle n'aura qu'à trop
chargé
donc pour les pois chiches le producteur
est situé à benne et ils viennent de
lutte de l'huilerie de la plaine de
versailles nous travaillons avec des
producteurs essentiellement locaux
donc des yvelines autant que possible et
sinon du ca reste du du français on a
fait un sourcil niasse et sérieux des
producteurs nous notre engagement c'est
vraiment la qualité des produits donc on
a on s'est mis en contact avec plusieurs
fournisseurs et on a sélectionné les
français les locaux les bios ou
agriculture raisonnée les pois chiches
sont prêts nous allons maintenant passer
aux haricots blancs et elle veut 500
grammes
[Musique]
pour notre lancement aujourd'hui nous
avons un taux au total 140 références
différentes sur notre site internet et
nous sommes sans cesse en train de
sources et de nouveaux produits pour
répondre à la demande de nos clients
chez nous vous pouvez retrouver aussi
bien dans toute la partie alimentaire
épicerie sèche sucrés et salés la partie
non alimentaire donc ça peut être les
produits d'hygiène et beauté les
produits ménagers des accessoires et un
rayon animal également donc là nous
avons terminé la commande pour le
chocolat en poudre la dame a choisi un
bocal
donc on retrouve bien la provenance est
ainsi que le conseil d'utilisation
la personne qui choisit un bocal pour sa
première commande le bocal et à elle
ensuite elle l'a payé et à la prochaine
commande elle pourra utiliser uniquement
du craft et recharger ses bocaux
[Musique]
ce périmètre c'est les communautés
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
saint quentin en yvelines et la haute
vallée de chevreuse on mon dessert aussi
quelques communes périphériques style
gif-sur-yvette ou encore sac et hulu
sienne il sera amené à s'étendre oui
mais pas tout de suite pour l'instant on
veut déjà pouvoir vraiment fidéliser la
clientèle sur le périmètre en question
l'activité a démarré doucement la
première semaine beaucoup de livraison
de votre équipe une collecte de notre
réseau personnel un familles annie voilà
et dès la deuxième semaine on a commencé
à avoir des commandes de clients qu'on
ne connaît pas parce qu'on a pas mal
communiquer notamment sur sur les
réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
voici votre commande dernière commande
oui votre première commande alors au
lieu de travail c'est pas fort pratique
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette livraison
express dans les temps
vous avez accepté ces mêmes choses
qu'avant je fais tout moi la passe
oui lamballe à versailles
[Musique]
là bas qui a commandé il ya la semaine
dernière et qui du coup nous a passé une
grosse commande là il ya une dizaine de
produits que aussi bien que ce soit
alimentaire il ya beaucoup appris
beaucoup d'épicerie
d'épicerie sèche chalets et quelques uns
produits ménagers je crois une lessive
est également des accessoires pour pour
la cuisine et la salle de bains au tout
départ se fier moi comment c'est connu
c'est parce qu'on a et on a emménagé
dans un immeuble neuf à voisins le
bretonneux donc on a emménagé le même
jour en fait tous les habitants emménagé
le même jour et j'ai eu le malheur de me
garer sur sa place de parking donc j'ai
retrouvé un petit mot sur ma voiture et
donc je suis allé m'excuser auprès
d'elle en sonnant à sa porte c'était ma
voisine de palier en fait et voilà
comment on s'est connus donc après on
était plus que voisine on était amis on
est on s'est rencontré en 2014 et donc
en deux
2021 on a commencé à réfléchir à a monté
notre notre société et à travailler
ensemble on sait que
la planète pas mal entre
part en tant que parent on a envie que
bonnes conditions et tous fois on a
envie de leur transmettre ses valeurs
faire en sorte que
bah voilà que tout à jallet en bicycle
tribu concret en notre antre
permettant à tout à chacun sont
différents déchets facilement une fois
on a envie tout un chacun puisse se
et à sa manière être entrepreneur
aujourd'hui
ça permet de construire quelque chose de
se sentir utile d'être concret dans nos
actions au quotidien
et
bonjour madame
alors je vous lis moi votre deuxième
commande c'est ça je crois c'est que la
première vous a plu exactement mais non
c'était top donc j'ai préféré le gym
j'ai commandé en plus de 20 ans
donc là on vient de livraison nous reste
un click and collect à finir de préparer
pour un retrait à midi donc suivez moi
vous fait du retrait en click and
collect deux fois par semaine le lundi
et jeudi enfin pour l'instant ce sont
ces jours là ça sera certainement amené
à évoluer donc entre midi et deux et le
soir à partir de 16 heures jusqu'à 19
heures
[Musique]
là ce sont des biscuits en fait de
feucherolles
qui sont confectionnés et fabriquer
là-bas c'est par les deux gourmands
voilà donc c'est encore une fois un
produit local un producteur local
[Musique]
est pour l'a donc moins qu'au monde
est prête à préparer
ces deux là ce sont des commandes en
retrait points de collecte pour
aujourd'hui voilà
[Musique]
i